[Musica]
Quando è stata l'ultima volta in cui
avete danzato
Immagino che alcuni di voi possano aver
pensato a una lezione di ballo vera e
propria a una serata in un locale con
degli amici a un momento di intimità di
abbraccio col proprio partner o magari
perché no avere tamburellato con le dita
sul volante della propria auto e magari
ciondolato la testa a tempo di musica
mentre guidavate per raggiungere questo
teatro ma io stasera vorrei fare in modo
che questa fosse per tutti l'ultima
volta in cui avete danzato
Quindi ora vi mostrerò quattro semplici
movimenti che forse avrete già notato
perché li ho eseguiti mentre stavo
parlando vi chiedo di ripetere alcune
volte e cercare di memorizzarli se vi è
comodo potete anche alzarvi in piedi ok
Questo è il primo movimento
ogni movimento lo ripeteremo quattro
volte
perfetto secondo movimento molto
semplice
chiudo le mani
terzo movimento
apro le mani
quarto movimento
Ok ora complichiamo un po' le cose Ora
cercheremo di metterli insieme e creare
un'unica sequenza che riparte sempre da
capo ok Quindi
1 2
4 e di nuovo 1
2 3
siete bravissimi facciamo un altro paio
di volte
2 ultima volta
due
4 perfetto bravissimo ora complichiamo
le cose ancora un po' di più e cerchiamo
di giocare un po' col tempo in modo da
rendere questa sequenza un po' più
interessante per chi le esegue Ma per
chi La osserva quindi lancio chiudo apro
lentamente
slancio chiudo apro lentamente
bravissimi
[Applauso]
in questo momento abbiamo fatto almeno
tre cose degne di nota abbiamo abitato e
utilizzato il corpo in maniera
leggermente atipica rispetto al solito
abbiamo creato una memoria collettiva Ma
soprattutto abbiamo cominciato a
insegnare al nostro cervello a
rispondere in maniera leggermente
diversa ogni volta che in futuro
osserverete una sequenza simile da
qualche parte mi spiego meglio sappiamo
che nel nostro cervello Esistono delle
aree che si attivano sia quando
eseguiamo un'azione come ad esempio
afferrare un oggetto
sia quando la stessa azione viene
eseguita da un'altra persona
tanto più conosciamo i programmi motori
per muovere il nostro corpo verso quella
azione Quindi verso quello obiettivo
tanto più queste regioni saranno attive
Quando osserviamo l'altra persona
eseguire il movimento
questo fenomeno che ha detto risonanza
viso motoria e uno dei meccanismi grazie
ai quali siamo in grado di comprendere
le intenzioni alla base del
comportamento di altre persone e questi
meccanismi sono stati trovati anche in
risposta al movimento complesso come
quello danzato Ad esempio se nel
cervello di chi danza in maniera
professionale rispetto a chi non ha mai
danzato
troviamo una maggiore attivazione di
questi processi quando i danzatori
chiediamo di osservare oppure di
immaginare di eseguire una sequenza
tecnica che ha richiesto anni di
preparazione in studio
alcune di queste regioni sono poi anche
attivate quando decidiamo se ci piace o
non ci piace un movimento questo Vedi
dire cosa se prendessimo la sequenza di
movimento che abbiamo imparato poco fa e
la ripetessimo per ore e ore ancora
arriveremo ad aiutare il cervello ad
attivarsi in maniera diversa ogni volta
che una sequenza simile fosse vista da
noi durante una performance di danza
oppure anche semplicemente camminando
per la strada
ma per lo stesso principio potremmo
anche dire quindi che tutta l'esperienza
di movimento che avete fatto fino ad ora
fa sì che quella stessa sequenza venga
percepita in maniera leggermente diversa
quasi unica da ciascuno di voi
questa esperienza acquisita detta anche
expertise rappresenta proprio una di
quelle caratteristiche individuali di
chi osserva che diciamo va modulare
l'esperienza estetica nel giudicare come
bello un movimento e rappresenta proprio
il primo livello di complessità quando
prendiamo in considerazione il cervello
e la danza
su questo livello si aggiunge poi un
secondo che è rappresentato da tutte
quelle caratteristiche specifiche del
movimento che appunto hanno un effetto
su di noi nel decidere cosa ci piace
cosa non ci piace
qui le cose cominciano a complicarsi un
po' Infatti il neuroscienziati almeno
fino ad ora per studiare un fenomeno
tanto complesso hanno dovuto prendere la
danza e frammentarle in tante piccole
unità ad esempio decidere di
focalizzarsi sul non so il numero di
passi che compongono la sequenza oppure
il tempo con cui risolviamo questi passi
o lo spazio in cui prendono vita
possiamo poi concentrarci focalizzarci
sulle relazioni tra più corpi nello
spazio o il rapporto tra corpo e musica
o con i costumi
per esempio se consideriamo il corpo
singolo il nostro cervello sembra
mostrare una per così dire una sorta di
preferenza quando il corpo è presentato
dritto nell' orientamento naturale
rispetto a quando è invertito Infatti
riconoscere se due posture corporee sono
uguali oppure diverse e più difficile
per il nostro cervello quando sono
presentate a testa in giù e guarda caso
L'orientamento del corpo nello spazio è
un parametro che cambia molto spesso
durante una performance di danza
parlando poi di preferenze sappiamo che
gli osservatori
ha mostrano Appunto una preferenza per
Quei movimenti con un grande spostamento
nello spazio orizzontale cosa voglio
dire grandi salti eseguiti col corpo in
cui il danzatore Proietta se stesso in
un'unica direzione
Nel caso poi di osservatori non esperti
sappiamo che c'è una sorta di preferenza
per elementi cinematici di basso livello
Cioè ci piacciono di più rotazioni molto
rapide
movimenti eseguiti molto Ampi ad esempio
movimenti di equilibrio oppure movimenti
di sospensione
la simmetria è un altro elemento che va
a giocare sulla nostra piacevolezza
estetica così come la sincronia ovvero
quando sulla scena I danzatori riescono
a cominciare a finire un movimento tutti
insieme senza alcun tipo di indizio
visibile
quando poi consideriamo delle sequenze
di movimento un po' più lungo un po' più
complesse Ecco che sembra gli
osservatori sembrano preferire Quei
movimenti che sono eseguiti con delle
dinamiche temporali varie ma prevedibili
uno studio Infatti ha mostrato che se
prendiamo una sequenza di passi e
accentuiamo i momenti di accelerazione e
decelerazione questa sequenza viene
percepita come maggiormente piacevole ma
difficile da eseguire rispetto alla
stessa identica sequenza Eseguita in
modo fluido e continuo
il rapporto inverso tra la piacevolezza
e la riproducibilità fa sì che siamo
attratti da qualcosa che non siamo in
grado di riprodurre e forse questo è il
motivo per cui poi andiamo a teatro e ci
lasciamo affascinare da chi ha fatto
della danza la propria professione
e qui direi che sta un aspetto
assolutamente affascinante ovvero che
danzatori performer coreografi riescono
a utilizzare nello stesso momento Tutti
questi elementi che noi siamo costretti
a frammentare per poterli studiare e ci
regalano un'esperienza artistica
completa quindi non solo ci riescono a
mostrare a regalare riesco a inventare
dei movimenti che sono piacevoli da
osservare ma attraverso il movimento
riescono a veicolare emozioni
significati creano delle drammaturgiche
complesse che ci trasportano in altre
dimensioni dimensioni che la scienza
Deve ancora cominciare ad esplorare
Quindi io spero che in questa sera sia
un po' più chiaro quanto sia complesso
insieme affascinante il rapporto tra
danze cervello e mi auguro che uscendo
da questa sala di teatro possiate notare
nel movimento osservato dei dettagli di
cui prima non eravate consapevoli e
magari individuare la danza proprio dove
non pensavate di poterla trovare
no E chissà che magari camminando per la
strada in un futuro osservando qualcuno
che si muove in modo strano alla domanda
Ma che cosa sta facendo possiate
rispondere eh sta danzando
[Applauso]
Grazie